Rainbow six experts in close quarters  battle and hostage-rescue  assembled from Special Forces teams  around the world the counterterrorism  units these are the elite American  operators the custom m120 compact rifles  developed for each through windows  floors and walls from the distance when  ash knocks better seek shelter  sensor activated pulse is capable of  tracking suspects heartbeats wherever  it's time  pretty lethal for a biometrics genius  secure doors and windows counsel carries  a portable bulletproof paranal that can  be rolled like a blanket but holds like  a fortress  you knows exactly how to get rid of  trouble  equipped with the brimstone ready a  remote detonate thermite can cut metal  like butter  I got visual  [Music]  you